take a look at this video from CNBC this
is Goldman Sachs CEO David Solomon
responding to a question related to ESG
this is vanguard's CEO just wrote this
recently said we cannot state that ESG
environmental social and governance
investing is better performance wise
than broad index investing our Research
indicates that ESG investing does not
have any advantage over broad-based
investing what do you think of that as
somebody who I think has advocated for
the ideas around DSG well I I'm I'm a
big advocate for climate transition but
it's just that it's a transition that's
going to go on over a long period of
time I think one of the things we do as
an asset manager is we meet the needs of
capital allocators and capital
allocators are interested in allocating
some Capital not all of the capital some
Capital towards Technologies towards
opportunities that are driving the
transition that are making the world
more sustainable you know for all of us
and so I think it's important for us as
an asset manager to participate what do
you make of the political blowback and
how is that impacted your thinking about
all this I I the the political blowback
really hasn't affected my thinking that
meaningfully I've always been of the
belief that it's important for us to try
to be constructive and allocating risk
capital and driving risk Capital toward
technologies that can accelerate the
transition but it's a transition it's
going to take decades
James I feel like you're gonna have a
field day with this one so the
questioner the interviewer is Andrew
Sorkin I actually think he did a pretty
decent job there in essence he's saying
hey these ESG funds don't really do much
of anything and immediately the Goldman
Sachs CEO starts talking about climate
transition but I don't know that the
average person who invests in a fund
that Goldman Sachs is managing is really
thinking oh what can I do for the
environment they generally want to make
a couple bucks on their investment
take it away oh my God I could talk
about this for the entire show can you
give can you give the people the
simplest I know my audience knows it but
can you give them the simplest uh
explanation of ESG first before we go
any further yeah so ESG it stands for e
is environmental s is social and G is
governance it's it's a measuring stick
that they're using to judge corporations
and institutions about how compliant
they are with whatever they whether it's
at the United Nations where ESG was
created in 2003 whether it's at Davos
whatever these you know Grand pubas and
oligarchs decide are acceptable
environmental social and governing
policies for corporations and
institutions uh that they score
institutions on how well they comply
with those particular mandates so it's a
tool of control it's actually a social
credit system for corporations in large
institutions so that's what ESG is it
hides itself under the the fake idea
that certainly good Environmental Policy
social policy and
um go it was corporate governance could
lead to better long-term investment
portfolios if they were done maybe in a
realistic way as opposed to under the
dictates of Al Gore or Cloud Schwab or
something like this but what the guy
said is is actually amazing what he said
is so shocking so we see now that ESG is
failing there's a gigantic Crusade
against esj which I'm happy to take a
fair share of the credit for starting
and and unfortunately or fortunately
whatever this fella is like I don't care
about the blowback I care about a
transition a complete transition of our
system and a climate transition he calls
it but this is a transition to climate
communism it's a transition to more
control centralized control more what
they call Global cooperation toward
their central control meaning everybody
has to do it or else there will be
sanctions there'll be fines there'll be
I don't know maybe they'll just destroy
our infrastructure or something until we
comply if you'd like more sane takes on
our insane World check out our direct
message clips playlist and if you want
to watch more full episodes of our live
round tables watch our round tables
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell